by picking up something that you said in
a previous publication about uh how
technological developments encourage us
all fantasy as to how Warfare can become
fast easy and decisive
um now we're we're moving on at an
extraordinary rate in terms of
technological capability so how do you
think that that uh remark now uh plays
in the background of AWS and are there
fantasies as it were which we need to
explode that may be the wrong word but
you understand I understand
um well thank you very much and thank
you for having me here it's always an
honor
um I uh then what my concern is with two
things first uh sort of technological
determinism
um the the new technologies
mandate a certain form of warfare and
the war follows where technology leads
and I'll explain why in a second I don't
think that works and secondly
um a sort of more General
a problem you can call it a fantasy it
has disastrous consequences which is
um the belief in the decisive first blow
um the surprise attack the the that
solves every problem and technology is
often seen as a means by which you can
achieve things that you weren't able to
achieve by other methods
I think you just step back a bit you
have to consider the um
a general uh just generally how War
developed it sort of laid I mean we can
see this dramatically at the moment in
in Ukraine dramatically
um we you can watch on social media
videos of troops engaged in almost
hand-to-hand fighting in trenches
something that would not have surprised
anybody had they had such imagery from
the first world war at the same time you
can get videos of Ukrainian Ukrainian
troops using the iPads to connect to
Starling to bring in
material Intelligence coming from
satellites and directing using another
Satellite Communication uh accurate
artillery to hit particular targets
these things happen together so I think
it's not that technology
is irrelevant or all gets lost in
Timeless character of War but it's
layered it comes on top of what's
already there and what's already there
uh it takes up normally the bulk of
activity if even if you just call it
Legacy systems in terms of equipment
on the second point on the problem of
the decisive first blow uh
it it goes right back to
um to the 19th century the the belief
that war is designed by a battle uh if
you win the battle quickly then you are
going to be in the commanding position
to get the political settlement you want
and because Wars are decided by battle
the best way to achieve surprise and to
catch the enemy underwears is going to
make all the difference and you and if
you you know go back in the historian of
these things you can find these themes
re-emerging all the time
so that the technology that made a
difference in the in the late 19th
century was the railroad
because that made an enormous difference
to Logistics as well as the gradual
Improvement to artillery which which is
more incremental in some of the uh
Fantastical Works fictional Works about
an invasion of of Britain that appeared
in the 1870s the first thing that was
done was to cut off the telegraph line
so these issues are always around I
think it got the technological dynamic
aspect of it became more important in
some ways as the
um as the prospect of battle receded so
when we when this leaders I think
directly into AI when you have the first
moves in the digital age
um
particularly the development of cyber
warfare you'll see references to an
electronic Pearl Harbor
that that one one day the plug will be
pulled out and all our systems will
collapse and everything will go black
because it's a massive Cyber attack uh
and I'll stop at this point because just
one thing to think about this was
exactly what was expected
on the 24th of February last year and it
was tried it wasn't that the Russians
didn't try but they failed and they
failed because people knew it was coming
and have taken measures to to mitigate
the effects so uh these are my concerns
not that we should dismiss the
technology or play down its impact but
we must put it in a wider context of uh
why and remember that war is a jewel
it's not uh it's not except on occasion
it's not one side just imposing its will
it's two Wills against each other and
they resist and find ways to adapt
thank you we all know that um
the political attraction of nice new
shiny systems which promise so much more
than went before
what sort of warnings do you think are
appropriate to in terms of political
Direction apart from reminding
politicians about this layered nature of
warfare
well I think it's always it's always
useful to do that one of the
difficulties with AI is
um it doesn't appear as bright and shiny
it appears as remarkable outcomes but
it's not like a precision-guided
munition for example I mean which did
appear as bright and shiny when you
could
guarantee that if you've got the
coordinates right and you have the range
right you could attack and reproduce
your destroying everything that created
a whole set of new images that have go
back to 1991 and the Gulf War made an
enormous impact because they could see
it happening I think one of the the
challenges of AI
um is that we see our our smartphones
being able to do remarkable things
and our students can discover how
somebody else can write their essays but
it's not
um it's not bright and shiny it it a
continuation of what
has gone before but with the cleverness
that people find it difficult to
understand I think that that's what why
I think people find it that I find it
quite hard to get one's head round the
full implications of what's going on
with AI
I think Lord Mitchell's got a
supplementary on this thank you Chan
hopefully you'll slap me over the wrist
if I go off peace but I do have a
question to ask you meant you mentioned
starlink yeah just to refresh that
that's Elon musk's um yes no orbit
um
satellite one of the things I've read
about it is that he is actually taking
the decision in Ukraine and as to who
can access it and who can't so here we
have a situation where
a high-tech businessman is deciding
foreign policy which has implications
for all the things we are talking about
do you have any comment on that yeah I
mean you're right to raise it I think
it's an important issue
um
I mean I think it's been the case really
since the 1990s the the relevant
technologies that are affecting so much
of all human Affairs not just Warfare uh
are developed by big companies largely
but not solely in America
and uh
they have an enormous impact so it must
kind of come in with Starling I mean
what happened at the start of the war
there was the ViaSat uh satellite which
the ukrainians had been using for
communications and the Russians
basically took that out jammed that very
effectively right at the start and musk
came in if he hadn't there would have
been problems with Starling we're
providing lots of terminals thousands of
terminals
that enabled Ukrainian government
Communications to continue aloud
zielinski to keep on talking to people
and also helped at the front line but as
you say
um musk developed his own foreign policy
I mean literally he proposed his own
peace plan
and when it looked like the ukrainians
might be able to attack into Russian
territory
uh he put a limit on what they could do
so it wasn't so much who could use it
it's just the the the there were limits
on their ability uh to use it to direct
stuff into Russian territory you could
also look at the role that Microsoft has
played uh
um absolutely vital in in Ukraine cyber
defenses uh the Microsoft
without getting the same attention as uh
as musk has played a very important role
so I think it's one of the things that
again we need to get our heads around
with this issue is that although there
are some forms of AI that only states
can probably develop and will develop
there's an awful lot that that's being
developed outside of the state the whole
thing obviously or all the
chatbt and so on it's not being
developed by States now China is
obviously going to be slightly different
in that but on the western side it it
means that the role of Corporations has
become important and you may recall
after the Snowden Revelations we're not
talking about well over a decade ago
there were deep anxieties amongst many
in in this community Google in
particular
that they didn't want anything to do
with the military they wanted this to to
be developed in a very benign way
um the address problems of climate
change and such like but not
problems of Defense now interestingly I
think one of the consequences of Russian
aggression is people can see the point
of Defense a bit more now and understand
why it might be necessary for Google and
others to take contracts and and support
the Pentagon in
in developing their at their AI work but
it I think this
uh
business military
interaction
is really important and as you say if
you've got a corporate leader who and
musk is will have to say it's a bit
unique in this but if you have somebody
like that
with their own agenda this is somebody
else that has to be negotiated with who
has to be persuaded and at one point it
looked like musk was going to pull the
plug all together
uh on support because it was costing it
money was expensive uh and quite complex
negotiations had to take place uh just
to keep him doing what he'd been doing
up to that point never mind going the
next step
you're Brown
thank you chair uh good morning
Professor Friedman
um I'm pleased to see you here
so this question is designed to allow
you to share your Reflections on the
UK's policy on AWS and to what extent
the UK government is has it aspires to
be anyway a leading voice in
conversations and international
regulation if I may I just would let you
when you're answering this question to
address a couple of my things one's an
observational is a very direct question
but the evidence that we've received up
until now is hardly surprising because
it confirms that we're aligning
ourselves fairly closely with the United
States although we're not aligning
ourselves as closely with the United
States in terms of their transparency
about you know their own development of
weapon systems
um and and and the context of the CCW
that has meant expressly that we've
aligned ourselves with the Australia
Canada Japan and South Korea who are
very sort of close uh small Club of the
nation states and not necessarily
representative of the International
Community and the the the the the point
I would really like to ask you if you
can help us is is you know what might an
arms control regime to regulate
autonomous weapons actually locally
and this you know this the current
International context
I just thought on on your first point I
mean clearly right the the UK
by and large is is on the light
regulation side of the debate lighter
than the EU for example
AI is an important feature of orcas the
second pillar of orcas so what's with
Australia and the United States a map
potentially
in principle is an area where you could
have
an alignment of regular I mean it
requires an almost an alignment of
regulations so you could have the
technology sharing that that envisages
which over the longer term could be
really quite important
the question of an arms control regime
um is is separate uh
I can't say any Arms Control looks very
promising at the moment I mean
and it's just worth noting that all the
enthusiasm for demining
and avoiding Minds in Warfare and just
how many minds are currently being laid
in Ukraine
the imperatives of War take you in
in directions which go against the man's
uh the tend to lie behind Arms Control
aspirations
it's also very difficult to
think through what it is you're trying
to stop
so for example
uh
autonomous vehicles
first got a lot of notice I think in in
Warfare with um
means of dealing with IEDs with
improvised explosive devices it made an
awful lot more sense to send the machine
to probe and broadened something that
looks suspicious and send a human being
now you wouldn't want to stop that
it's a good thing to do it's better than
having humans in that position
now if you then start to imagine
robots going into war then or swarms of
drones then then you've got another
problem but the technology that allows
you
to start directing drones to do
reconnaissance may not be that different
to the technology that allows you to
direct to direct them to to drop
grenades on trenches and if you're
again if you if you look at
the current War
um and I think this is true for on the
Russian side as well but we know more
about the Ukrainian side
there's not a lot of just improvisation
that goes on so and it almost goes back
to the the previous question
the times when the everything was in
control of the state so the stated signs
an agreement not to do something
you some trust that it might not happen
actually it's much more fluid now than
the participants in Conflict are much
wider
ameriability to direct technology itself
there has been quite a lot of work done
on the possibility of arms control
regimes
um
but it was done in slightly easier to
easier times and I would have to say at
the moment I
would not be optimistic I think the
restraints are going to have to be
self-generated
and we're going to have to work out the
things that we don't want to do and
would rather not see and hope that
others are are thinking in in similar
ways
bringing back to the original question
which is you know there is a process at
the moment going on an international
process which has been going on for a
long period of time
um and hasn't produced very much so the
the question is are we are we leading in
that or as we as many may think that we
are breaking that process
I don't know enough to to to give a
definitive answer I think the um
I think the steam has gone out of a lot
of that work at the moment uh I think
also people you know one of the
difficulties with International
negotiations and this sort of technology
is you can find yourself addressing a
problem that's a year and a half out of
date uh or even if it's five months out
of date or a month out of the day
because something happened that you just
weren't anticipating uh I I think you
can work on general principles
uh the uh and obviously the importance
of keeping humans in the loop
about
the dangers
of
misinformation and fakery and so on all
of these things you could have general
principles about
but I I what I find difficult to see is
how this can become the basis of a
reliable International agreement I think
it it's important that we think about
the ethical and legal issues connected
where with AI and there are lots of
groups who are doing a lot of work on
that so it's not as if that this isn't
neglected but it tends to be on a
national regulatory basis or a
european-wide regulationary basis or
maybe you know within the alliance but
it's not I don't think it's going it's
going to be only with difficulty that
you bring in France China let alone
Russia into the
and thank you for coming along the the
um the formal supplementary on this
question said is our existing
Battlefield regulations including Rules
of Engagement targeting directives
command and controlled procedures
sufficient to give them the use of AWS
and we want in this question also to to
get your views about
um the extent that you think there
should be what's called meaningful human
control placed as a sort of a safety
mechanism within the potential Fielding
of um artificial intelligence in weapon
systems
um
these sessions are a little bit like
um Staff College syndicates where half
of the question is about impressing the
directing staff and half is trying to
influence the views of your compatriots
military manner in the session so far
I've tried to let the others know that
to my perspective the battlefield
although hugely chaotic is a highly
regulated environment and it has all
these things of
um targeting directives Rules of
Engagement weapons type weapons free
stand to Roa all those sorts of things
I haven't mentioned a noodle Loop to
them now an ooda Loop is
UDA is I think he's a some ex pilot from
America John Boyd Boyd and and it is
observe Orient decide act and it's a
it's one of the rhythms of battle that
you're continuously doing this you
observe you oriented that you gain your
information that leads to a decision and
then you act and I think for weapon
systems we could probably reduce that to
inform decide Act
now to me I think that you could have
every element of that informed decide
Act
uh every element of that Loop could be
subject and linked by Ai and there are
some systems fielded today particularly
those that in
self-defense of surface ships from
inbound
um Air Attack the whole thing happens
within a context of speed and response
and relative ease of discrimination and
proportionality that you could delegate
that in a fully automated sense
but you could also have meaningful human
involvement in every stage of that or
just one or two stages of that depending
on the varying contextual considerations
of time discrimination proportionality
and legality and I have no difficulty in
the ability to do that
because I come from the fundamental
premise is that as a battlefield
Commander you cannot ultimately delegate
legal or moral responsibility to a
machine but you can exercise judgment in
what you might call permitting
automaticity
and
I I can get my head around that but it
does involve an awful lot of high
quality training in an understanding of
the variable geometry of the permissions
that you would need to be taking a risk
judgment against in order permitting
automaticity
so I come from this from I think this is
all manageable within what we've got but
I would be hugely
desirous that you challenge that or else
help me win my fellow colleagues over to
my view
we see a table full of open minds here
it's like a Staff College Syndicate
um
so the divided up into two
and you could argue that the the problem
of working out whether something is a
legitimate Target
maybe exactly the sort of thing where AI
can help
um
you you may recall uh during Kosovo
the endless arguments that took place
over targeting now some of these were
political
um about how far you can go what was
appropriate what was not appropriate
some of them required particular
information intelligence about what uh
about how things have been changing over
time then you have to bring in the
International humanitarian law and so on
and so forth actually seems exactly the
sort of thing where AI can't doesn't
have to make the decision for you but
can give you the material very quickly
exactly the sort of thing where they are
to the question of
um
what do you do if if uh if you have to
activate your defenses
again this is exactly where AI makes an
impact
uh where where it's in Houston you can
see it being developed so just take and
it's a good way to get into how how
Information Technology over the decades
has made a difference so go back to the
Dowding system in 1940
um in the Battle of Britain
as you will recall require the the
sending in
and what they have to do is work out
what was most important where they were
going and what was available to deal
with them and they dealt with it very
quickly but it's all done by human
beings
moving those things on the table and so
on
fast forward to Israel's Iron Dome
is doing exactly the same thing
it's working out where incoming missiles
are likely to land which ones can be
safely ignored which ones must be dealt
with what's available to deal with them
how do you prioritize and does that in
seconds because that's all they've got
there's just not room for a human
intervention in that process
it works because it's defensive
um because people uh understand that if
the if if they had to have a human being
deciding all of these things it would
just be too late
um and that's true obviously
on on a ship I always think again going
back to the 1991 War
um there was a famous episode where um a
royal Navy ship uh an officer on a royal
Navy ship had to make a decision about
whether to intercept an aircraft going
towards
um
uh an American ship
or missile he's a missile I was a
missile
um
it was a civilian airliner not a missile
and
it sounded it was a missile and
correctly attacked it and they then they
couldn't work out how he knew and
eventually they went back and and saw
that the radar Trace began at the shore
um and that obviously meant it was a
missile rather than an aircraft to
become from some distance and this is
normally taken as an example of
intuitive thinking
um uh how you can make good decisions
even if you're not deliberating because
you don't have time now that all that
could be worked out that's again the
sort of thing that you can assume the
new technologies will will facilitate
when you're when you're activating
defensive systems that's all you may be
able to do now it's going to be very
different though which can come back to
the first point about
um how you decide how to Target uh when
when you're working out what to attack
and why when you're taking the
initiative and that does seem to be
somewhere where you will absolutely have
to keep humans in the loop
um because you don't want to take these
bold decisions on the say so
um of a computer however good the
algorithms
the danger appears to me is if the
person who is delegating automaticity to
the machine
doesn't genuinely understand
the potential envelope The lethality of
what it might do I.E somehow become
sentient and goes off on its but so long
as
a weapon system can be so tested and
proven
that the individual Commander making the
delegation of automaticity
knows the envelope of lethality is
unleashing
then the the humanitarian laws of
Distinction and proportionality can be
still adhered to is that a fair and I
think it is I think it it
look
in war
um
things go I mean things go wrong uh it's
a systems that you thought
were wonderful breakdown uh other things
land in the wrong place and cause
enormous and terrible damage that nobody
expected or wanted
this is why war is a terrible thing
um but at the same time
the narrower you can frame the problem
the more specific you can make it the
more you're likely to be able to stay in
control of the issue of how things
develop and I I mean that's my sort of
general rule for trying to understand
the role of AI is
it can deal with it can deal with narrow
problems where there's a lot of
information
um and uh the less reliable the
information the more you it may lead you
astray The Wider you've set the problem
the more you ask it to do the more
confusing it's going to get so if you if
you can keep that's one way it seems to
me of keeping it in control which is why
the air defense problem is a
particularly good example
before I come to Lord Hamilton I should
observe that Philip Wilcox the captain
of HMS Gloucester is a very good friend
of mine alas I attended his funeral last
month
much much too soon much too early
Lord Hamilton yes um before I come to my
question I'd like just to go back to um
your concerns that you have first
Freeman Bud international law law as to
whether it has any role to play in this
you're not the first witness to cast
doubts on that
um if we're to look at it
in terms of the United Kingdom is there
a national solution to regulation
where there isn't an international
solution so could there be some
committees set up by Parliament which
could actually oversee the procurement
of AI and indeed the use of it on the
rare occasions when we went to war I
mean I think there's a little fun
questions indicate uh we do have law
it's we do have international
humanitarian law and and the uh and a
lot of the discussions as I understand
it have been whether you need anything
extra in addition to that or whether
that can cope
um so uh it's not it's
I'm not wholly skeptical of
international law
um but it tends to work best in terms of
broad principles rather than trying to
itemize everything that can and can't be
done and I think you you know the
principles
um that you see under development being
discussed for AI in the civilian sphere
um tend to tend to follow that the
problem is interpretation and
application uh
ah
I I really I mean I find it very
difficult to say with it
AI is the sort of thing
that needs a committee by itself or
whether it's something that
um
inquiries such as this can deal with as
part of a a broader a broader framework
uh
you know the the
it gives a problem with very fast moving
technology uh also I suspect that I'm
getting well out of my comfort zone here
it's also going to be a question of case
law uh it is uh what had been the the
the challenges that have come up and how
have they been uh addressed in the past
you know historian as you will see I
keep on going back to to past Wars and I
can think of examples that illustrate
particular things but we're in a very
new area now and we may not have the
examples that we were we were
anticipating I mean you know just the
final point is
um you keep on coming back
to the in this area and I think maybe we
want to discuss a bit more that it's not
um one state imposing its will on
everybody else we don't expect that it
states engaged with each other uh and
trying to frustrate each other and this
makes it very hard to work out exactly
where the boundary should be and where
the limits are because you don't quite
understand what what sort of resilience
you need
so I I'm I think it's very difficult to
develop very specific
um instruments to deal with these
developing problems principles yes
applying International humanitarian law
certainly but but I'm I'm not so sure
that there's uh we're going to find it
very easy to to take it beyond that
yes I think that uh half answers the
next question which is because can we
create a defense policy which is
resilient to this rapid change that's
going on
I think we
I think we can
um
again it comes back to my opening point
the
we've got to remember everything else
that's going on
um it's only one part of a defense
policy uh you know
we've been living for over 30 years 40
years in some ways with the idea that
Modern Warfare is all about smart bombs
and smart weapons and so on but you can
run out of smart bombs and smart weapons
very quickly as as we saw and you go
back to dumb bombs uh quite quickly uh
you know the methods by which Russia is
fighting at the moment rely an awful lot
on artillery barrages
and uh and rather hopeless infantry
assaults
um so in the sense that they've gone
backwards as they've used Stefan again
as you all know one of the challenges of
British defense policy at the moment is
is filling an empty cupboard that so
much stuff has had to be passed on
correctly in my view to Ukraine that
there's not a lot left I think and if
you don't have your basic ammunition
there's not it's going to have trouble
picking up everything else so I think we
have to this is why I think you have to
see the impact of these the new
technologies in very particular area
it's not going to transform every aspect
of War uh it you know it can mean
um that an infantry company actually is
better situational awareness
then
um what they had before but if they
don't have the artillery the artillery
ammunition to fire it's not going to do
them much good so I think it's it the
the challenge is to keep these different
um
uh called layers uh integrated and not
to neglect
the the old ones uh because in the end
it's the weapons that that can make all
the difference in the war so the the
challenge I think is to identify those
areas
which AI can really make a difference
and remember it's basically just about
decision making
AI itself doesn't kill people or destroy
things it supports decision making that
enables other things to do to do that
obviously if you link it with autonomous
weapons and so on that then it it starts
to give you a capability which you
wonder about the role of humans now
again sorry to keep on going back to the
current wall but it's the best evidence
we have
um if you just look at the way that
drones have developed even during the
last
uh 14 months and the roles that they're
playing
what you what actually you've seen
is some of the more sophisticated drones
become quite problematic because they're
jammed because electronic warfare
techniques can be improved to deal with
them which is why I don't hear about the
Turkish drone so much
while a lot of other drones
um cheap commercial ones
many from China are being used on the
front lines and adapted in some ways
often
quite cleverly and it doesn't matter if
they can be a lot of them are lost
because of electronic warfare you may
think it's quite a good deal if they if
they're knocked down by an air defense
missile
um
the it hasn't gone in the direction
people anticipated
the importance I mean what what's I'm
very careful about drawing lessons from
a war that isn't yet over but we're at
the stage we're at at the moment is
drones are becoming more important
um but cheaper and less sophisticated
than some of the ones with which we
started but that then is linked
with the with Star Lincoln and the uh
and the intelligence feeds and so on so
it's not as if all that element is
absent
um but uh sometimes a robust basic
technology does you just fine
where the AI makes a difference is the
decision making it is providing you with
the evidence
um and the options and you know the
risks are there but but also the
possibilities
before I come to Lord climate Jones I
think baroness hodgson's got it good
thank you can I
okay on what saying about the decision
I absolutely understand
I can see that AI is very good at
systematic decision making
but what it lacks is empathy empathy and
do you see the lack of empathy being fed
into complex decision making
would be a problem
indeed I mean I
it's um
it's not going to order it's not going
to give inspiring speeches or or
um
uh Pat somebody on the back and and and
uh
write consoling letters back to uh to
bereave family I mean it obviously
hasn't all over that uh it it's um it's
algorithms what and
but what it can do is on the basis of
the information it has and the data
attached interrogate that very quickly
um and if you've asked it the right
questions with the right parameters
we'll give you
a helpful answer
um now my worry about it and I think you
can see this
already in lots of the applications in
everyday life
um
is that
it comes out with answers that you don't
understand
um that you can't quite work out where
it comes from because you don't know the
waiting
that's been given to particular factors
so you know the first thing any of us
ever learned about about these about
computers and these systems as rubbish
in rubbish out
um uh and by and large when you're
getting rubbish out you could go back
and you could see the rubbish that had
gone in which biased
the the decision but if you don't know
or they don't understand all the inputs
um then it could I think it can get
quite bewildered I think this is I think
this is a general problem and if you you
know if you look at a lot of the systems
that may be used in Social Security or
tax now to to test particular things
unless you actually know what uh you
know they may give an answer at the
other end about whether you get a
benefit or not unless you actually know
uh how well they've understood the case
law however how well they've understood
the benefit system uh how well they've
applied particular questions you just
can't be sure but that's all you've got
and people will encourage you know be
encouraged to rely upon all of this so
this
um this seems to me where the sort of
awareness of the limits of what you've
got becomes very important and and how
you get around that when lots of
decisions become an awful lot easier if
maybe quite low level decisions but it
can be quite important uh is is
um
it's quite a big challenge so that's the
the first thing
um
I'm
you know the classic examples that tend
to be given about decisions which
machines are very bad at taking uh
without you know the the standard
driverless car problem about if you if
you're about to crash and you've got
pedestrians on the pavement which way do
you turn
um now how you train a machine to make
that decision for you is is very hard so
I think uh I mean all one can do is put
the problem on the table because I'm not
sure uh other than encourage those who
are designing the systems to think very
hard ask the legal and ethical questions
as they go along uh try to imagine that
the various contingencies that they may
face these are the sort of things that
need to be done but it goes back to you
know the early points I made these
systems work best with a narrow problem
and a lot of information
the the more you're asking them to do
you know why driverless cars you might
Trust on a Motorway but they're not in
the middle of London uh it because the
the the contingencies just get too
complex
and one of the problems with a lot of AI
uh obviously eased the more that the
the more complex and sophisticated they
they become is something that we may
notice as being a bit Anonymous
anomalous
excites our curiosity may just seem to
be a bit of outlying data which they
don't understand and can be ignored or
may throw them completely off course uh
so these are the sort of things that
um when people are trying to make
decisions relying on the support of AI
if they don't understand
uh how the decisions how the algorithms
are working what has been the critical
data how it's been weighted then you
then you are and you you are you are
indeed you're not having just decisions
that aren't very empathetic but but are
also pretty poor
clementines
um morning
um what you said earlier about drone
development feeds very nicely into into
my question
um there's a widespread Narrative of an
AI arms race but very few examples of
autonomous weapon systems exist now what
do you believe is the reason for that
this seeming mismatch and I've got a
couple of examples uh Dr dear um told us
when he came along he said when he was
asked uh uh to provide an example of a
major AI project within the mod he said
he was stumped
um and then we've had uh I think other
examples uh of actual Weaponry uh where
they could be the subject of an arms
race of phalanx ciws
apparently in and loitering ammunitions
and I I wondered what you um thought
about this whole question of of arms
race uh when actually
um
it it appears that you know we may not
be really moving into a very
sophisticated uh era it may be more as
you say about the sort of small uh um
drones that aren't uh that sophisticated
yes I mean
obviously one has to be careful about is
they'll go back on what I'm saying said
before must be a bit careful about
drawing lessons from what the ukrainians
have been doing because they're not the
Americas
um the Americans would have thought this
will very differently because they had
air power and uh and quite a lot of
stuff that's much more sophisticated
than has been provided to the Ukrainian
so it depends who's fighting
um over what uh
the problem with it with the notion of
an arms race is it is it assumes
everybody's trying to do the same thing
uh so uh I mean
one of the advantages uh the US
demonstrated with its drones was
loitering in the war on terror
um you would have drones being operated
from
thousands of miles away
um over critical targets watching what
was going on and then deciding whether
to unleash a weapon now everybody can
try to develop drones like that
one of the reasons the Americans could
do that is that nobody was shooting back
at them
so there's two sorts of arms races
there's the arms race where you all both
sides are trying to do the same thing
and then there's the arms race where one
side is trying to work out how to
neutralize the capability of the other
and that's that's the most important
illustration I mean that's that's the
one that goes on daily uh and you can
see it in the Cyber domain
um away from the military sphere there's
a constant battle going on constant duel
as hackers try to develop new ways of
getting into other people's networks and
those in charge of those networks trying
to find new ways of stopping them and
detecting it so this is constant it goes
on all the time and most countries and
that's again relevant to the Ukraine war
because
Ukraine has had a lot of support in
dealing with Russian cyber attacks
enormous support uh despite the fact
that these have probably been the most
sustained attacks ever that's the sort
of arms race of which we're a part of
and that continues
um you know an AI is just a development
of that so the thing to watch
littering drone
make the most of the
is going to be doing to interfere
that's the arms race I think
all these different bits are are linked
but they can be treated in a way
separately so you've got them 100 the
basic
uh resilience
your ability to keep the
anything else
or uh
um then
your machine learning is if they've got
nothing to learn with it's not going to
so
that they're trying to direct and all
they all have their old histories and
Technologies
um the the that need to be understood
and and how their systems integration
Works how they're brought together is
supposed to do so
uh different parts of this can be
disconnected like we're discussing with
with drones and still make an impact but
they may have more impact if you can
integrate them much more with a wider
Network so that's I that's a long-winded
way of saying I'm not
um I don't think it's useful
particularly just to think about
everybody charging off in the same
direction and seeing who gets there
first it's a much more complex
interaction with a variety of component
parts
and this fundamental problem of
uh offense and defense of the
interaction between the two opposing
sides it's really helpful just a short
supplementary you mentioned earlier we
talked about starlink and so on do you
think the heavy involvement of the
corporate sector in AI development and
so on makes it bigger difference in this
uh Weaponry yes
but this is
um you know you go back into the history
of computers they wouldn't have
developed without military contract
um
and uh
names of the of the 50s a few large
corporations but basically the state
a man uh
as the microchips got smaller and
smaller and more could be done with them
all the law takes effect and and all of
that then in the 70s you get the the
personal computer uh and all of and all
of a sudden
um stuff
individuals could do never never mind
companies and then
was a turning point in this uh you know
up to 1991 only the military
and then lots of reporters following the
Americans around uh suddenly realized
for you uh
Art phone has got
a smartphone now
things that were very privileged for the
military
a few decades ago but we just now expect
them to take them for granted so there's
been a civilianization of
the consequences of that is it's been
developed by civilians it's not being
developed by the military anymore
come to ordinance that's a different
matter because you want
um
uh too much I mean companies could
fulfill the orders from the from the
ministries of Defense but the ministry
of defense is still going to give the
orders
you don't want private companies
ordering their own um shells so uh
in the the the this whole issue is one
where the the
civil military divide and what once
started with the military and the strong
and will
what often we're talking about is
um
debates has been good
therefore
went off the shelf
although potentially
um more vulnerable to interference so
you know I think these are the sorts of
debates but the bias in this is certain
Now with uh with with the big companies
developing and our International
companies
um you know that you know Apple
um maybe baseball in in in the US
um but if it's worried about its Chinese
market
um that affects its attitude to
encryption and so on on the relationship
between uh defense and offense that you
were talking about a moment or two ago I
seem to recall that W.S Gilbert said
death stalking would be a very fine
sport if only the deer had guns which
they provide a side light on that uh the
Lord Bishop of Coventry
thank you thank you Lord and greetings
from Kenya
thank you very much Professor Friedman
for your presence I'm sorry not to be
with you in person
I hope you can hear me okay Lord chair
yes indeed
Professor mayor take you back to a
couple of things you said earlier
um when you're talking about a defense
system you said they were simply not
room for human interaction because of
the speed and then later you talked um
reassuringly about AI being their its
function is to support human decision
making
the question I have is how that relates
to the sort of warning that we've been
given by a number of people about the
risk of escalation
um risk and escalation through speed and
the difficulty of predicting the
response of other actors
and and so my question is simply if
those risks are real
how can they that that risk of increase
escalation
um how can that how can they be
mitigated how can they be um responded
to I have another supplementary
um which we let Professor Friedman have
a go at that one first uh Lord Bishop
another good escalation so
um
escalation is is a strange concept it's
uh it can mean two different things
first it describes a tragedy
um
things since you step on the escalator
and you can't get off which is the
original meaning
why the term came into use
and suggests a situation in which the
human beings have almost lost control
because of the passion and intensity and
confusion of war and then
um almost in response to that view of
escalation it became a deliberate
process
something that you controlled so you may
recall it keeps on coming up the famous
escalation ladder which was developed by
Herman Khan in the 1960s which had 44
different rungs and you could decide
which one to go up and when
um I think alarmingly the first nuclear
one was about rung 13
and
lots of different ways of using nuclear
weapons but the his point was that you
um that these were deliberate decisions
you own only over time
did you get out of control to start with
you were under control
we said these these
um ideas go side by side but you know
first point to emphasize is some
escalation is very deliberate
um you do it because you're losing and
because you want to move to a new level
which you think you might win and that's
a lot of the concern about escalation in
this war
um on the Russian side is you know what
happens if if Crimea is threatened what
happens if Russian forces have been
humiliated would he go nuclear right
personally I don't think he would but
you can see where the concern comes from
the first thought is
um
escalation that's inadvertent okay it
comes from conf uh
friction the fog of War if you like
and I think people are concerned
um the the
that either you you have General
confusion as you said before you don't
quite understand why things are
happening uh why decisions are being
taken by the machine the evidence
they're being they're giving you all
there is deliberate interference
so if you look at
um
the ability to create fake news a very
credible fakery now start a rumor
these sort of things can lead
to politicians under a lot of pressure
maybe to make it a deliberate decision
but on the basis of
a false information
that has been deliberately
inserted and I think this is an area
where again before this war probably
still there was quite a lot of concert
how do you work out what's exactly
happened and anybody who was following
events closely knows you know you hear
um you hear a report of some atrocity
which is immediately denied and it takes
a while to work out exactly what's been
going on and sometimes it it turns out
to be true in which case that has an
effect on the Readiness of the other
side to escalate so
um I I I don't think you you you you're
you can't just say that escalation is a
is a negative if a country's trying to
win a war and at times it will
deliberately do so and whether what
Ukraine has done uh over the you know
from starting off uh preparing Molotov
cocktails uh to to now uh getting pretty
long range capabilities that can do real
damage
um to Russian assets uh that's a form of
escalation but it's also their their
attempt to to stay in the war and and
win it but there is this element where
big decisions might be taken on the
basis of very bad information perhaps in
some cases deliberately inserted perhaps
just because uh things are a muddled
because they're they're confused
when fast moving situations knowing
exactly what's going on is very hard
we're much better at that than we used
to be I mean you know it's important to
stress that the
um
the by and large the new technologies
help a lot
in situational awareness commanders now
are far better informed than they were
often they were completely in the dark
and much more vulnerable to to rumor and
um
and muddle uh than before so you know
we should acknowledge where things have
got easier as well as where they may get
worse I think I probably as with all
these systems
um when they're working fine it's much
better when they make a mistake
precisely because we trust them to work
fine uh and the the consequences can be
larger Bishop do you want to follow up
with your second question
yes thank you and thank you Professor
that's very helpful and and in many ways
reassuring and my supplementary may send
a little left field but I think it's
it's related
um we've had a number of sort of
um warning Bells run by people in the in
the industry there was uh well the
latest uh and and uh maybe the most
credible uh Jeffrey Hinton last week
there was the letter uh from the open
letter from a number of scientists that
were supported by Elon Musk
um and now that this talk of a pause we
I think we've all felt uh that that's
very unlikely to happen but is there
something that nevertheless we need to
take heed off there and if I could sort
of maybe make that a bit more specific
um I think my sense as you've talked
about a I
um are being applied in a fairly narrow
sort of sense
um
it seems to me that their warning is
that that a general intelligence is not
as far off uh as as we might have
thought and well is there anything to
heed there is there
um sufficient anticipation of that uh
event
it would seem yeah um
well obviously this is a big issue
because
um
I think
there's been a sudden sort of moment of
awareness which chat gbt I think
uh is responsible for where all of a
sudden
an amazing capability is accessible to
any to everybody and uh it's a shock to
the system
um you know dude uh
in the court to students
you may not respond to that
I couldn't resist
um you you you have this too
um but anybody who's tried to use
the the I think the phrases it tends to
hallucinate
um so that uh after a while when it
can't make the obvious point
because it
tentative connection and this is where
is
um because it it can
create a confidence in in what you're
getting now I think these uh these are
all part of the same problem
it's very difficult I think to to say
you you just pause this
um
it's not so difficult to say there are
certain principles and concerns that are
very serious
applied
um and discussed
um although there are obviously some
applications of all of this that can be
developed quite cheaply and quite easily
these really big models like the produce
gbt and and the equivalent can only be
done by companies in states with very
large budgets
um so that some control can be exercised
that way and they need to think it
through
you need to do much more which I think
is a discussion at my college yesterday
um
about
and is actually relevant to the staff
College as well uh which I'm sure you
can imagine syndicates get very tempted
to get somebody else to write their
essays for them
um is to teach people how to use it so
rather than saying it was never touched
chat gbt
um he said all right do that as your
first
run now let's go through and work out
how reliable it is where it's gone wrong
and use that as a learning Aid in itself
so I think part of the challenge is to
develop a critical understanding of the
technology make people literate about
what the technology can and can't do
yeah that's
um that's an important part of going
forward
um I think
the it's it's clear that there's a
general capacity being developed here so
you know my line specific problems uh
large amounts of data well if you're
China and your specific problem is
social control and you've got something
on everybody and facial recognition and
so on as well
um you may you know AI May well work for
you
um if that's what you want to do I hope
it's not what we want to do
um but it but it's one of the ways
legal question that
you know the facial recognition is is
already quite a Hot Topic
um because you can interrogate a
database of lots of faces and the people
aren't wearing masks and appear then you
can pick them out except sometimes you
pick out the wrong person so I you know
I I think it it's it's a literacy issue
it's understanding
um that just because it's
um it's come out of the system doesn't
need to say it's accurate uh go back to
the rubbish in rubbish out problem and
that we need to develop a critical
understanding of what it can do uh I
think that's a that's a more
um realistic course I think than saying
just stop because if you stop you you've
still got everything we've got at the
moment and that's just the final Point
um
okay I'm I'm not sufficient at
technologists to to understand how true
all of this is
um these really big
um
systems
um they use up an awful lot of computing
power
an awful lot of electricity uh are
dependent upon
um high quality microchips and you need
if they're going to develop further you
need
um
more miniaturization and development of
quantum computers and so on and it's all
linked
um
we don't know I mean we've just lived
through a period where we just assume
that everything just speeds up amazingly
it may not necessarily be true there may
be a point where it Peaks I mean AI
you know was a big thing uh in previous
decades and then it subsided because
they just couldn't find a way of taking
it much further then
at 10 12 years ago it suddenly took off
again
um so just the sheer capacity
constraints may also become come to be a
fact
my wife is a rural Dean so I'll pass on
your advice about using chair gbt for
first draft
um with Sunday in mind
uh Lord Fairfax the Cameron oh thank you
uh thank you Professor for your evidence
so far very interesting thank you
um I have um a short supplementary to
stuff you were talking about earlier
about drones in Ukraine but maybe I lost
my principal question first
um which is as regards prospective
regulation is there any valid
distinction to be made between the
develop on the one hand between the
development and acquisition of AI weapon
systems and secondly their use
yes I mean it's a standard issue with
nuclear weapons isn't it no that was an
analogy I was thinking
um uh it's uh I don't know what are the
international discussions going that way
at the moment I don't know whether that
was really what I was thinking I don't
know I mean I I think the um
I think it's very difficult
to tell
governments or companies not to carry on
developing I don't think it's difficult
to pose the legal and ethical questions
to them and political questions
as they do that this choice is to be
made about what sort of applications you
develop and and how you develop them
um which and you know do you do you go
for large numbers of simple drones or or
a few big ones I mean these are the
they're not that different from normal
procurement
uh decisions uh
and as I've tried to emphasize not all
we shouldn't just assume that everything
to do with AI takes us into a new and
dangerous area some of it is really
quite helpful
um and may make for better decisions and
less damaging outcomes uh
so you know
so the basic principle is that uh so
long as these are human choices to be
made and you're facilitating human
choices then any Weaponry there were we
can see developing
um can be used for terrible purposes for
shameful purposes for illegal purposes
or it can be used for defense
um uh but so that's not a reason not to
develop it and purchase it but it is it
is a reason to think hard about how it's
being used I think when people
you know the major concern people have
is you know sort of the Terminator
problem of sort of going rogue and uh
um and suddenly deciding
um the the the people who
uh supposed to you're supposed to be
defending are are are actually the enemy
um and because you're a robot because it
tells you this is a bad idea so off you
go
um and uh but you know these are risks
in any conflict uh you know Blue on Blue
attacks happen because the information
is poor
um and uh
the
all that you know is is it you look
vulnerable and you take a decision uh to
deal with it to deal with the threat so
um I don't think one should
uh
assume that the the class of problems
that are developing here are different
in kind
to those with which we're quite familiar
from the past
resulting from the uncertainties and
confusion of War
um
and the difficulties of decision making
the challenge is to is to is to use AI
to make those decisions better rather
than to make them worse and when it
comes to I don't think we will get to a
situation where people will allow the uh
the systems to take offensive decisions
on their own and I've indicated they
already take now defensive decisions but
to take offensive decisions on their own
I think will be much harder but you will
see swarms
have drowned being set against
enemy systems that are communicating
with each other and so on that that
seems to me perfectly plausible
um it's it's a new way of doing what
armed forces have always done but I
don't think it poses a particularly
different kind of problem to the problem
that we've had just at a different sort
of Technology
if I may in the time available a very
quick uh supplementary to a discussion
earlier it was we talked a lot about
drones in Ukraine are you aware yourself
or have there been any anecdotes of uh
drones loitering drones Cami cars your
drones or others
identifying a Target and then themselves
you know
so you haven't heard that we haven't we
haven't crushed that threshold yet no no
I was always being a human somewhere in
the loop saying right see this and no no
the the the the the the the the uh it
just doesn't happen no all the imagery
we have is of operators
um I mean they don't load it for very
long either
identifying targets
uh either for themselves which
are all for artillery or also very much
what's up friends thank you Lord chair
thank you Professor I found this very
very uh helpful
what would be the ideal capability that
should be in-house at the mod in order
to make the right procurement decisions
and the right partnership decisions you
talked about the civilization of
Technology even though the mod has some
great technologists many will be
attracted to the private sector with
their big comp packages and flexible
work from home policies bean bags sleep
pods granola dispensers
Etc and so how should we be thinking
about the in-house mod capability
um it's an interesting question
um
I think it's worth looking at gchq
um not particularly I mean they seem to
acquire everything digital as it is so
maybe they'll end up playing a more
important role than this uh
how does gchq maintain its Excellence it
um has exactly the exactly this problem
and it's partly
um
because it appears to be able to pay
higher than
higher rate because otherwise you're
just not going to get the people I mean
the number of people have pointed out
some of the very important technology
jobs in in the Civil Service are going
at ludicrous salaries at the moment that
would require people to almost halve
their pay if they're coming from the
private sector Cheltenham may not be
as big a problem creating an atmosphere
of
intellectual
Excellence feel you're doing something
important that it's really making a
difference and a flexibility of people
going in and out of the private sector I
mean quite a lot of people as I
understand it come back to gchq after
making their pile if you like or doing
well enough in the private sector and
then feeling they like the special
challenges so I think it's not that
different to running a university I mean
if you want to have a good Department
which depends on really bright people
who understand something you've got to
give them the support
and the intellectual excitement that can
come with working on these topics and
the feeling that it's an important
Public Service
um now how much you need to do in-house
I think is one of the the big questions
which I don't I mean I don't even claim
to know the answer to
uh
I think you you know we have this
country still a lot of very good
technology companies who are working
hard on this whether you need to
replicate what they're doing in-house or
work out ways to work closely with them
accepting that this raises security
issues maybe for some of the people
involved ethical issues they don't want
to work on or military matters so it's
not simple
but for a lot of areas I I would have
thought you really do need to look at
public private Partnerships rather than
expect everything to be in-house I just
don't think we can we have the capacity
um
to do enough when there's so much good
stuff elsewhere but you still need
um this again goes back to a very old
debate about uh what needs to be done
in-house and and what can be contracted
out you still need high quality people
to evaluate what you're getting
um to know the right questions to ask
even if they're not going to be doing
all the development work themselves I
think that I would see is a as as vital
to this is is is having
um
the people who are working on this in
government uh with sufficient Authority
and competence to be able to assess
properly what they're getting and to ask
the right questions
so and to make sure that these legal and
ethical and political questions are are
fed in and you're not just giving as can
happen contrast to people to do what
they would have done anyway which they
find uh interesting but they may not
actually be serving the national
interest I think I can guarantee you
that those questions will resurface when
we have ministers in front of us later
in our inquiry
um the Barons juicy did you want to
follow up on that yes just briefly um
later on
and then buying stuff off the shelf if
you like can you ever envisage a
situation that rmod which I must tell
you I don't think as an of as an
exciting and fascinating place can you
can you imagine that their mindset might
be that they would buy off the shelf
rather than want to control it
themselves
they have historically they haven't been
great at that
um
and but you know
I don't know them there's been a lot of
very long procurement processes
um that uh because they very specific
military requirements take longer and
then the turnover of civil servants and
so on means they take longer still and
we know the problems whereas buying
regularly off the shelf in areas where
it's appropriate
can can speed things up
a lot so it's again it's not a new
debate
they are capable of buying off the shelf
um
I think I think you know the the
challenge
the challenge is always
being very clear about your
specifications and what you want and
then when you've got and then letting
the contractor provide them rather than
keep on changing all of that but I don't
know I don't think I don't think it's an
impossible thing for them to do and
again we're talking largely software
here
um and I think that that's very
different from
you know the big vehicle project which
uh uh are the ones which tend to go on a
long time and just one final tiny
question
um do you believe that if the ministry
of Defense
um are getting over the problem of
paying you know much higher than their
normal scales are doing so by having
using Consultants do you think that a um
using Consultants who are not obviously
members of staff and maybe not haven't
got the same sort of if you like
um ideas about loyalty and all the rest
of it do you think that that can work in
a in a way that would make sure that
they were able to compete with private
businesses that can seemingly pay
whatever they like
I think I mean I
I haven't got enough practical
experience to to give you a very
authoritative answer
I think the role
unfortunately Consultants
are a way of getting round some of the
limitations of the civil service but
doesn't they often can provide a more
expensive service but not always a
better one
and uh
uh
I think in areas like this which are so
important and are potentially
demanding and exciting and so on you
need to you want to create that sort of
Iran again I think you find a tchq
um the the the the the uh
that it's not you know it's not purely
transactional
I think baroness Hudson has wants to
pick up a point from earlier and then
I'll come to Lord Mitchell who I think
has a question on the UN Charter
marriage thank you
um I just wanted to focus this for a
moment onto the UK and defense defense
of the UK and what capabilities that the
UK might need to develop to combat the
use of
um Ai and automatic weapon systems by
enemy combatants as well as defend its
own systems
um
I think it's part and parcel of the
general development of Defense
policy uh
the the the the the standard questions
of the defense of the UK
um which you know come back to the fact
that fortunately we're an island and and
uh that helps a lot uh so that there are
big air defense questions and and these
are an AI indicated it's helpful in Matt
that there's questions about
expeditionary forces and the sort of
problems they may face
um but I think as I've indicated I think
that some way away from
really effective use of autonomous
systems
um uh well again it's just part and
parcel of drone and anti-drone
development there's another issue
um which is uh sort of a broader
security question which goes back to the
whole cyber
area where as I've indicated there's a
constant offense defense due going on
much of it directed against criminals
rather than other states which
is a challenge which AI I think will
make more of a challenge
that that I think is
an area where you know if you're talking
about
the role of the city for example the
Integrity of the banking system all of
these sorts of things uh you you can see
opportunities developing that
um
well maybe malign States but certainly
criminal organizations will wish to
exploit and I think the
and then you know you have the other
things suggested before about uh
attempts to manipulate the information
environment and so on these are things
that that will will increasingly need
attention and I think when you get to
asking about the legal and ethical
uh questions about AI development
um
your
and the possibilities of developing
pretty plausible social media figures
who turn out to be completely complete
Fabrications uh these are again the sort
of the sort of issues that are going to
become increasingly important
Lord Mitchell
yes thank you little chair
yes United Nations
um so would the inherent right of
self-defense in article 51 of the UN
Charter permit states to deploy
totally autonomous autonomous weapon
systems in self-defense
um
I mean
I mean article 51 is a very useful
article
um
simply because it allows you to defend
yourself without getting the rest of the
security Council
to to support you I don't think it makes
any difference
to how you do it I mean go back to just
War
principles in international humanitarian
law for your guidance on what you do
um but what you decide to do in
self-defense
um
uh
is uh depends on what capabilities
you've got the challenges that you face
and yeah the the ethical questions but
there's there's no there's nothing that
says
you can't you've got to use what you can
now
the the issue is our autonomous system
is going to be any use and any in any
value with that not a matter thing still
is a big debate which and we'll want to
avoid it but I don't think we should see
them as the Ultimate Weapon that you
only bring in to play when you're faced
with the most dire threat
um
if they're going to develop at all
they're going to be part and parcel of
the Lord
excuse me
um
National capabilities
I'm sure that answers your question but
I don't I don't see it as being a a a
special situation
Professor Freeman thank you very much
I'm sorry that the configuration of the
room today means that much of the
dialogue has been long range but you've
taken our inquiry evidence onto a whole
new level and I know that my colleague